committed that all adults will be
offered the first dose of the vaccine by
the end of july we're on track to
deliver that and i'm absolutely
delighted that today
half of all adults have now been
vaccinated including the prime minister
yesterday
and and yesterday was in fact the
biggest day of vaccinations
in this country's history the team are
doing an amazing job
and is this vaccination program enough
to avoid a third wave
well the vaccination program is our
route out of the pandemic
it will help us to protect people and we
know that these vaccines
protect you but we also know that they
protect
those around you and they make it less
likely
that others your loved ones will catch
coronavirus too
and of course for all of us they're our
root out so
i'm just delighted that so many people
are coming forward
and getting the jab when you see what's
happening in europe warnings of a third
wave a lockdown happening in paris
do you feel concerned well of course
we've got to be
vigilant because we know that this virus
spreads ruthlessly and we've set out the
road map for a cautious
but i very much hope irreversible exit
from these lockdowns you know we set out
the dates
carefully and you know the the first
big step will be on the 12th of april if
the
data show that it's safe to make that
move after of course
and children going back to school a
couple of weeks ago the whole point of
the roadmap
is to be cautious and careful
understanding that this
virus lives only to spread and of course
it's the vaccine
that allows the road map to be to
to be there at all we've seen from the
first wave
a year ago and from the second wave in
the autumn that we saw it first
on the continent in europe and then we
saw it here
so of course we're absolutely vigilant
but there is no sign that we won't be
able to make progress
as set out in the road map here
thankfully the number of deaths is
falling very very fast
by more than a third a week we are
seeing
something of a flattening in the number
of cases but they're still coming down
and of course the vaccine rollout is
going in
is going incredibly well so we
we we're on track to meet the
commitments we've made to
vaccinate the whole population offer
that first job by the end of july
and to meet the dates set out in the
roadmap but we'll stay vigilant and
we'll be cautious and careful in our
approach
and in terms of europe do you believe
that travel corridors and the vaccine
passport system do you think that is
effective and could protect us from
potentially
what is happening across the across the
news channel
well we've set out in the road map the
approach to international travel which
is that there shouldn't be international
travel unless it's absolutely essential
until the 17th of may
and after that we have a global travel
task force which i
chair alongside my colleague the
transport secretary
with all of the travel companies on how
we
can open up international travel safely
and we'll make a judgment
ahead of the 17th of may about whether
it's safe to do so
and set out more details when when we've
seen
uh the impact and a bit nearer the time
i'm sure you've seen the comments today
by
mike tilsley from sage saying
international travel
extremely unlikely this summer he's got
a point doesn't it
well we have to be vigilant and we've
set out
the steps in the roadmap that there
should be no international travel unless
it's absolutely necessary until the 17th
of may
and then the global travel task force
will
make a judgment and work with the
industry on how
quickly and whether we'll be able to
reopen and how we can
reopen in a way that is safe should we
should we be able to do so that's a
judgment that we should make
in in a few weeks time not now
and of course we'll look at the rates
both here and abroad and the impact of
new variants
to understand uh whether it's safe to
make that move
finally there'd been a lot of question
marks over
the astrazeneca vaccine something you
obviously were heavily involved in
sort of funding the start of seeing some
of the pictures on our tv screens in the
past couple of days including
with the french prime minister how do
you feel at the end of what's been a
pretty
a difficult week for those involved in
that vaccine well the whole vaccines
program has been such a huge
team effort and they've been challenges
all along the way
but we're we're making great strides
and really it's a national success story
that everybody could be
could be proud of and i'm very very glad
that uh european countries are now
restarting their vaccination program
using the oxford astrazeneca jab
the european regulator has been clear
throughout that this is safe
and effective it's very good to see that
backed up by the french prime minister
taking the oxford job himself yesterday
along with ours and lots of my
colleagues and a record number of people
across this country